and in related news tonight my renowned
libel attorney Charles Hart or sent a
letter to the New York Times demanding a
retraction and apology it's also a
preservation letter over there fake news
story that all but accused me of murder
full details Hannity calm at Sean
Hannity on Twitter what they wrote was
false it is provably false then rather
than do the ethical honest journalistic
thing which would be correct and that's
retract and then apologized what do they
do they secretly stealth edited their
mistake to me an admission of guilt and
the stealth edition by the way rendered
their phony headline false more evidence
of wrongdoing but let's be clear there
is no lie the mob and the media won't
tell no slander they won't spread no
hoax too insane to pass off as actual
news when I said journalism is dead and
buried in 2007 I thought I was right I
had no idea how right I was
and tonight the media is nothing more
than extension of the Democratic Party
and radical extreme socialism the DNC
the media mob they are one people tied
at the hip with one goal their goal is
to beat Donald Trump any way possible in
190 days at all costs mark my words the
lying the smears the slander the
besmirch meant the politicization of
everything will only get worse